welcome back to CBS this morning the
Justice Department is now looking into
the death of Elijah McLain
to decide if a federal civil rights
investigation is needed police
confronted the 23 year old as he was
walking home from a convenience store in
Aurora Colorado last August he died just
days later
Colorado's governor has ordered a review
of the case Jamie yuccas spoke with
Maclean's father she's in Aurora just
outside of Denver Jamie where does this
investigation stand right now well
Anthony late last night the interim
chief of Aurora police told us her
department will cooperate fully with the
federal investigation she's also looking
into three officers who allegedly
re-enacted what happened to McLane and
took pictures of it meanwhile his father
Layne Mosley says he misses his son
everyday it was just a bundle of joy I
mean just my baby my baby boy lewane
Mosley says his son Elijah loved animals
and played the violin he died 10 months
ago but his death is now only coming to
light because of the death of George
Floyd who like Elijah told police I
can't breathe
what would justice look like for you yes
everybody held accountable for their
actions
stop 23 year old Elijah mcclain was
approached by police after a 911 caller
reported a suspicious person in a ski
mask off assert detain mcclain who is
not armed and was not accused of
committing any crime police said McClain
tried to reach for an officer's gun but
it isn't shown on the police body camera
they placed him in a chokehold and
called paramedics who administered
ketamine and anaesthetic when you heard
that
ketamine had been administered what went
through your mind don't understand it
just don't understand it dr. Kevin
McVeigh me is the medical director for
Denver's emergency medical response
system and says neighboring Aurora has
similar protocols when it comes to the
use of ketamine by paramedics
ketamine's saves lives when used in
these severe severe agitated people but
if you listen to the video from the body
camera which fell into the grass McClane
seems to make clear statements including
not having a weapon and that he doesn't
mean to cause trouble
police reports state that McLain was
given 500 milligrams of ketamine because
paramedics estimated his weight at a
hundred kilograms or 220 pounds
according to his autopsy report McLain
weighed 140 pounds dr. McVeigh nee
explains his dose should have been three
hundred and fifty milligrams we know now
the results criminal defense attorney
Randy Zelan is not associated with the
case but says there are too many
variables to give paramedics the power
to use an anesthetic like ketamine you
don't have the opportunity to understand
and to spend the time to determine the
right dosage Louie Mosley's attorney
mari newman in the most obvious cases
officers shoot black people but likewise
tasers can be lethal choke holds can be
lethal
ketamine can be lethal what do you miss
the most about him not being here
the state has opened an independent
investigation into the officers who
arrested McLain who are still employed
by the Aurora Police Department the DEA
had originally said there was
insufficient evidence to prosecute the
officers and they were cleared by the
police departments Review Board Gail
boy Jamie every time I look at the video
it's very difficult to watch and when
you look at the full transcript of what
Elijah said at the time when one line
always sticks out to me
I don't even kill flies I'm different I
don't kill flies I don't have a gun and
then the administration of the ketamine
is very very difficult still a lot of
questions in this story thank you very
much